un rappel réglement sur la base de
l'article 70 même si j'ai peur de faire
un rappel réglement qui est en train
peut-être un rappel à l'ordre mais
j'allais je me lance tout de même
normalement madame la Présidente on doit
avoir plus de liberté d'expression à
l'intérieur de cette émission à
l'extérieur j'ai été avocat et j'ai
plaidé devant les tribunaux
correctionnels en matière de droit de la
presse pendant quelques années je crois
n'avoir jamais vu un seul magistrat qui
aurait condamné à responsable politique
parce qu'il aurait dit un autre qu'il
était lâche et encore moins comme une
otarie car communautariste n’étant rien
à une injure c'est le développement
d'une idée politique et je vous renvoie
au Larousse alors ça pose une difficulté
parce que nous sommes ici dans une
enceinte politique où nous débattons et
nous échangeons parfois même de manière
vive c'est aussi l'histoire de cette
assemblée sur des idées politiques nous
nous faisons depuis des semaines traiter
de fascistes de nazis de pétainiste sans
que jamais une seule fois un seul des
députés qui ont prononcé ces mots
inadmissibles ne soient ne fasse l'objet
d'un quelconque rappelle à l'ordre alors
je considère que la moindre des choses
c'est tout de même que nous ayons dans
cette émission une liberté de parole qui
soit supérieure à ce que nous aurions si
nous étions à l'extérieur sur un plateau
de télévision ou dans les médias par
conséquent madame la Présidente je
considère que les rappels au règle les
rappels à l'ordre qui ont été effectués
m'apparaissent aller à l'encontre de la
liberté d'expression qui est inscrite
dans la Constitution
je vous remercie pour ce rappel au
règlement Madame Le Pen je j'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure et je c'est ma ligne
depuis que je préside cet assemblée que
les débats que nous avons dans cette
hémicycle doit être doivent être
respectueux des parlementaires du
gouvernement des citoyens qui nous ont
élus et je considère que les injures
tels que le l'utilisation du mot lâche à
l'égard d'un ministre ne sont pas
respectueuses et constituent une
infraction notre libre notre règlement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je l'ai
sanctionné concernant le mot
communautariste il y avait un contexte
Madame Le Pen ou j'avenais de rappeler
cela et cette attitude de respect
minimal que nous devons avoir les uns
envers les autres pendant notre débat et
j'ai considéré de ma libre appréciation
de présidente de séances que le respect
minimal n'était pas assuré par l'emploi
de ce terme juste après un rappel aux à
l'ordre de ma part mais je vous rejoins
sur un point il est important dans une
enceinte démocratique où s'exprime les
élus de la nation que la parole soit la
plus libre possible dans le respect je
dis bien dans le respect des uns et des
autres et moi je ne sais pas ce que vous
considérez comme étant le respect des
uns et des autres mais moi je considère
que la façon dont vos députés ont
interpellé les deux ministres tout à
l'heure pendant les questions
gouvernement pour moi ça n'est pas
respectueux donc les rappels à l'ordre
sont parfaitement justifiés
donc nous allons maintenant procéder à
en au vote solennelle s'il vous plaît
vous ne me coupez pas s'il vous plaît
nous allons procéder au vote solennelle
sur le projet de loi portant en mesure
d'urgence relatives au fonctionnement du
marché du travail en vue du plein emploi
donc chaque orateur par groupe a un
temps de parole de 5 minutes le premier
orateur sera madame Astrid Panossian
Bouvet pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
il y a un bouton c'est celui-là
c'est bon c'est bon par contre c'est ce
bouton
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre chers
collègues nous avons examiné la semaine
dernière le projet de loi portant mesure
d'urgence pour atteindre le plein emploi
je l'ai dit avec le ministre il leur
rapporteur que je salue ici à l'occasion
de la déclaration générale à l'ouverture
de nos travaux il s'agit d'un premier
train de mesure et non la totalité de ce
qui doit être fait pour permettre
d'atteindre le plein emploi et mieux
encore le bon emploi il s'agit néanmoins
d'un texte nécessaire efficace et juste
il est parce que nous avons pu avec ceux
qui l'ont bien voulu l'améliorer par nos
débats je dis bien avec ceux qui l'ont
bien voulu parce qu'une partie de cette
hémicycle a travaillé à l'esprit les
situations concrètes des travailleurs
des demandeurs d'emploi et des
entreprises françaises nous avons
enrichi ce texte de propositions de nos
collègues du MoDem d'horizon des
républicains ou bien encore pour un
amendement de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
je dis avec ceux qui l'ont bien voulu
puisqu'une autre partie de cette
hémicycle a travaillé comme attendu avec
comme seul intérêt le bruit et les
fausses le son de morale nous avons dû
entendre les promoteurs du droit à la
paresse où les ennemis d'un patronat
fantasmé nécessairement cupides ingrat
et insensible nous avons également dû
entendre les pourfendeurs d'une
préférence nationale nauséabonde et
indigne à contre-courant du principe des
assurances sociales basées sur le
travail et non sur la nationalité
décidément
décidément difficile de masquer un ADN
xénophobe vieux de 50 ans fêtait encore
[Applaudissements]
fêtez encore tout récemment
c'était encore tout récemment dans cette
hémicycle l'emploi il y a ceux qui en
parlent et ceux qui agissent en sa
faveur
ce texte
ce texte vous le savez fixe d'abord le
cadre et le cap de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage
madame fameuse nous avons écouté les
besoins de l'économie nationale dans un
contexte centaine de milliers d'offres
d'emploi non pourvu nous avons écouté
aussi et c'est le plus important
l'aspiration de nos concitoyens pour qui
le travail peut être une source de
dignité et d'émancipation ce pour qui
l'assurance chômage et ce qu'elle doit
être et doit rester un revenu de
substitution temporaire assortie si
nécessaire d'un inconvénient au retour à
l'emploi ceux aussi pour lesquels les
employeurs doivent revaloriser
rapidement les grilles salariales dans
les branches à minima conventionnel
inférieur au SMIC si elles veulent
attirer ou garder des salariés et des
demandeurs d'emploi à qui le futur
France travail messieurs et Madame les
ministres devra aussi assurer un soutien
actif pour poursuivre les efforts
engagés sur la formation professionnelle
et lever les freins monétaires n'est pas
non monétaire tels que les gardes
d'enfants et simplifier l'accès aux
allocations chômage 40% de non recours
ça je vous ai dit ici c'est inacceptable
ce texte promeut l'emploi stable dans un
esprit de justice et d'équilibre là
aussi pour l'employé avec le bonus malus
des entreprises qui abusent des CDD et
pour l'employeur avec une lutte contre
les abandons de poste non justifiés car
non déplaise à certains ces abordons
sont une réalité sur le terrain des PME
aux associations je vous encourage à en
parler avec les acteurs de vos
circonscriptions et non toutes les
entreprises ne mettent pas
nécessairement en péril tout leur
salarié lorsque c'est malheureusement le
cas ce texte ne remet nullement en cause
toutes les protections existantes un
abandon de poste qui relève de
l'autoprotection ne sera jamais pénalisé
le tout limite donc les abus possibles
et continuera de protéger résolument
ceux qui en ont besoin
ce texte enfin donne les moyens de
simplifier le parcours du combattant de
la VAE enrichie par l'idée de création
d'un vrai grand service public de la VAE
cet article n'a soulevé aucune objection
de fond comme c'est le cas avec
l'apprentissage une personne pourra
accéder
son pour accéder à l'emploi et à la
mobilité professionnelle grâce à la VAE
je pense tout particulièrement ici au
personnel médico-sociaux qui dans la
pratique exerce souvent et déjà des
fonctions plus larges que ce pourquoi
ils sont reconnus et rémunérés ils
pourront en bénéficier je pense
également aux procédant dont
l'expérience pourra être valorisée dans
les métiers du soin et bien au-delà ils
pourront aussi en bénéficier et donc
vous l'aurez compris le groupe
Renaissance votre a pour ce texte je
vous remercie merci Madame Panossian je
me vois contrainte de prononcer un
rappel à l'ordre parce que vous avez
utilisé à la tribune le mot xénophobe à
l'égard d'un parti politique je venais
de rappeler qu'il fallait avoir une
attitude respectueuse les uns envers les
autres
la parole est à Madame Laure La Valette
pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas folle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon seul madame l'heure la Valette à la
parole s'il vous plaît mes chers
collègues
madame la Présidente Mesdames messieurs
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues depuis un moment nous
connaissions le gouvernement comme un
cabinet de conseils en communication
voilà que nous assistons à sa mutation
en cabinet comptable outre votre
politique de l'emploi et celle du
salarié jetable et interchangeable les
Français qui travaillent ne sont pas des
statistiques dans un tableau Excel ce
sont des gens qui vivent ou plutôt qui
survivent avec des préoccupations
concrètes un frigo à remplir des enfants
à élever des passions à faire vivre et
ce implanter dans un territoire donné
bref des individus dont l'existence ne
peut se réduire à des flux et des stocks
numérisés ce projet de loi finalement ne
contient aucune mesure permettant de
ramener durablement les 5,4 millions de
chômeurs vers l'emploi votre réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui vise uniquement
à culpabiliser les chômeurs est un
nouveau coup de rabot dans notre système
de protection sociale nul n'a besoin de
boules de cristal pour affirmer cela
durcir les règles d’indemnisation ne
ramènera pas les chômeurs sur le chemin
du travail mais peut-être qu'à défaut
d'indemnités vous préfériez leur fournir
un scooter pour livrer des repas contre
un salaire de misère un scooter ou
plutôt un vélo compte tenu de la
difficulté à trouver une station-service
ouverte dans la septième puissance
mondiale vous préférez sanctionner le
demandeur qui ne trouve pas d'emploi
plutôt que de répondre à la crise de
vocation qui frappe notre marché du
travail mais en allant toujours plus
loin dans votre fuite en avant vers plus
d'ubérisation vous ne créez pas de
l'emploi mais de l'instabilité oui
l'ubérisation du marché du travail est
un véritable fléau social alors quand
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ce gargarise de
la création d'un million d'entreprises
en 2021 nous rappelons que plus de la
moitié d'entre elles sont en réalité des
auto-entreprises ainsi votre politique a
effondré la productivité de notre
économie fragilisant notre modèle social
pour retrouver cette productivité il
faut à l'inverse valoriser les métiers
reconnaître leur utilité et assurer leur
stabilité monsieur le ministre huit
Français sur dix considèrent que la
demande d'une augmentation immédiate et
générale des salaires et justifiés que
proposez-vous en ce sens rien pourtant
les dépenses contraintes augmentent et
l'inflation sur les achats de la vie
quotidienne galope et étouffent nos
compatriotes dans un contexte de
déclassement généralisé nous devons agir
d'urgence et prioritairement sur les
revenus afin de rendre attractive de
nombreuses professions car le premier
frein à l'augmentation des salaires vous
le savez c'est avant tout le coût que ça
la représente pour les nombreuses TPE
qui offrent l'essentiel des emplois de
notre pays nous proposons donc une
exonération de cotisations patronales
sur les augmentations de 10% des
salaires pour tous les salaires jusqu'à
trois fois le SMIC chers collègues
parlons maintenant priorité nationale
l'immigration et la chair à bosser des
capitalistes à vide personne n'en est
dupe et vous chers collègues de
l'extrême gauche nupes vous devriez
avoir honte d'accepter une situation si
déshumanisante pour ces travailleurs
étrangers qui acceptent d'être
sous-payés là où nous considérons qu'il
serait utile au développement économique
de leur pays d'origine ne vous en
déplaise l'instauration de la priorité
nationale à l'emploi éviterait cette
situation en ne donnant pas d'autres
possibilités aux employeurs que d'offrir
des salaires plus élevés pour recruter
des Français ne vous en déplaisent cette
priorité nationale n'est pas un totem
que nous brandissons mais bien une
mesure plébiscitée par les français
puisque 54% d'entre eux se déclarent
favorables à son instauration et ne vous
en déplaise
et ne vous en déplaisent c'est sur cette
priorité nationale qui ont été élus 89
de vos collègues premier groupe
d'opposition à Emmanuel Macron dans
cette assemblée
alors monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues nous voterons bien entendu
contre ce texte considérant que les
Français devront de toute façon attendre
2027 pour qu'un gouvernement se soucie
réellement de leur retour à l'emploi je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Mathilde panot
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre collègue le chômage c'est la
faute des chômeurs au boulot les
feignants voilà comment résumer en
substance les propos que vous jetez à la
figure des 6 millions de chômeurs de ce
pays car ce texte n'exprime rien de plus
que votre haine viscérale pour les
personnes privées d'emploi peu importe
que vous ayez déjà fait une réforme
désastreuse il y a deux ans seulement
avec pour conséquence 20 000 ouvertures
de droits par mois en moins une baisse
de 40% des indemnités de 400 000 à
locataires et une baisse de 17% pour
plus d'un million de chômeurs peu
importe puisque l'objectif était atteint
bravo vous avez fait deux milliards
d'euros d'économies sur les plus pauvres
et Madame borne a même été promu
première ministre probablement pour
récompenser une certaine habileté à
persécuter les chômeurs
peu importe que vous soyez responsable
de la pénurie d'emploi dans le pays si
bien qu'aujourd'hui on compte une offre
d'emploi pour 17 chômeurs pourtant les
emplois ne manquent pas il vous
suffirait de les créer notre pays ne
manque ni de banquier ni de trader mais
de 50 000 assistantes sociales de 100000
soignants de 230 000 personnels dans les
EHPAD de 300 000 paysans de 7000
chauffeurs de car scolaires de 1200
conducteurs de train de 4000 enseignants
de 12000 forestiers de 250 000 personnes
pour rénover les bâtiments plutôt
qu'assumer vos responsabilités vous
optez pour le mensonge que n'avons-nous
pas entendu dans cette hémicycle entre
ceux de la minorité présidentielle
jusqu'à l'extrême droite qui fantasme
mon cœur avec le Medef une épidémie
d'abandon de poste pour justifier la
suppression des allocations on arrive
qui nous parle avec des étoiles dans les
yeux de la relation employeur salariés
comme d'une merveille de l'existence en
passant ceux qui ont une connaissance
qui a un ami qui lui-même un voisin qui
lui-même a un frère chômeur et dont il
paraît qu'il roulerait sur l'or avec 960
euros par mois bienvenue au café du
commerce ici la vérité est un devoir
moral facultatif quand elle devrait
pourtant vous faire dire que seul 36 %
des chômeurs sont indemnisés que 54%
d'entre eux vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté que 40% des allocataires
travaillent en même temps et que le réel
problème c'est le non recourt droit
comme l'affirme un rapport que vous avez
soigneusement dissimulé mais après tout
après tout que connaissez-vous du
chômage peu de choses à vrai dire tant
la macronie fait tout pour lui échapper
vous lui avez même substitué une
assurance privée plus connue sous le nom
de la République des copains grâce à
elle l'ancienne ministre de la Santé
Agnès Buzyn s'en va à la Cour des
comptes Jean-Michel Blanquer déchu aux
élections et recasées comme professeur à
l'université d'Assas Brigitte
bourguignon et promu à l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales madame
manuel wargon est placé à la tête de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
tout est tous sur remercier pour des
mauvais mais loyaux services sans passer
par la cause chômage sans même que leurs
qualifications n'aient été vérifiée eux
qui ont pourtant laissé un souvenir
périssable de leur passage au ministère
cartel est la dissonance cognitive qui
traverse ce texte quand il s'agit de vos
amis c'est le placard doré en revanche
le commun des mortels est un bouche-trou
tout juste bon à prendre n'importe quel
emploi emploi que vous refuseriez pour
vous-même vos proches ou vos enfants la
macronie s'occupe avant tout des siens
la mise en place des chômeurs en dit
long sur votre certitude de ne pas être
un jour exposé à la situation que vous
auriez organisé vous devriez étendre
l'oreille collègues quand sont de vos ex
collègues députés et parmi eux les trois
quarts qui la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale à allègrement mis
en état de nuit en juin dernier nous
disent qu'il peine à trouver un emploi
sachez quoi qu'il en soit que les
chômeurs n'ont rien d'une altérité
indépassable bien que vous vous fassiez
une si haute opinion de vous-même
leurs désirs ne sont en réalité pas si
différent des vôtres il veulent un
travail digne payer selon leurs besoins
partir en vacances de temps en temps
nouer des relations épanouissantes et se
sentir socialement utile le regretté
David Greber disait un être humain privé
de la faculté d'avoir un impact
significatif sur le monde cesse
d'exister voilà où réside votre violence
dans votre certitude que vous seul
seriez intéressés par la qualité de
l'emploi que vous occupez mais nous
n'avons aucune illusion sur vous il
s'agit d'un texte de classe et lorsque
vous l'aurez voté vous n'aurez réalisé
rien de plus qu'un vote de classe je
vous remercie
je vous remercie pour le groupe
pour le groupe les républicains monsieur
Stéphane Viry
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre la réforme
de l'assurance chômage nous l'attendions
et à cet instant nous l'attendons encore
le gouvernement pourtant l'avait annoncé
avec force au début de l'été en juillet
2022 nous devions avoir un texte
puissant clair à l'automne répondant aux
besoins du marché du travail aux
tensions de recrutement des entreprises
dans tous les secteurs d'activité
économiques à ce stade il n'en a rien
été
pourtant Monsieur le Ministre madame la
ministre une réforme de l'assurance
chômage au service de l'emploi s'impose
certaines de nos entreprises sont
confrontées à une importante pénurie de
main d'oeuvre ce qui pourrait laisser
penser que nous sommes quasiment arrivé
un seuil de bashumage le taux de chômage
est effectivement de l'ordre de 7,2 %
mais votre projet de loi à ce stade
n'apporte aucune solution
il est transparent en matière de
formation
il est silencieux en termes de mobilité
il est évanescent en termes d'insertion
professionnelle et ne s'adresse pas à
cette à celles et ceux qui constituent
ces 7% de chômage structurel et de
longue durée
à ce stade des débats nous restons
encore interrogatif sur votre vision de
l'assurance chômage
quels sont vos orientations sur la
gouvernance de l'assurance chômage
quel avenir concret pour le paritarisme
de notre pays
quel est votre souhait d'aboutir à une
revitalisation de notre système de
d'assurance chômage ce mécanisme de
remplacement d'un revenu pour celles et
ceux qui sont privés d'emploi ou alors
avez-vous l'intention de modifier la
donne mais en ce cas là il faut nous le
dire pour qu'on puisse apprécier la
porter la philosophie de votre vision là
encore à ce stade de nos débats rien
hélas pour comprendre ce que vous voulez
faire
et faut-il le dire mes chers collègues
si nous en sommes là aujourd'hui
c'est le fruit de la non considération
du dialogue social et de l'effacement
des corps intermédiaires du précédent
quinquennat si nous en sommes là c'est
l'issue le résultat de la loi avenir
professionnel de 2018 qui a abîmé qui a
dévitalisé le dialogue social et qui a
conduit à une nationalisation de tous
ces sujets qui concernent en premier
chef les partenaires sociaux vous avez
des vitalisé ce sujet et désormais il
nous faut bien trouver des solutions
objectivement votre projet de loi est
décevant vous l'avez convenu vous-même
c'est un texte d'attente c'est un projet
loi intermédiaire mais à ce stade compte
tenu de l'importance du sujet du marché
du travail et de la lutte contre le
chômage et de donner aux entreprises les
ressources humaines dont ils ont besoin
votre projet de loi nous laisse sur
notre faim
ce projet de loi a fortiori nous
contraint car comment refuser l'article
1er qui permet d'indemniser les chômeurs
dans quelques jours dès lors qu'il n'y
aurait plus de textes permettant de le
faire
ce projet-là nous oblige à être
responsable responsable ça a été notre
ligne de conduite dans l'examen de ce
texte depuis le départ nous avons
cherché à être force de proposition pour
compléter pour densifier autant qu'il
soit possible votre projet de loi nous
avons eu satisfaction notamment sur
l'article 4 portions sur la valorisation
des acquis de l'expérience l'amendement
voté aux commissions à déverrouiller le
système et a permis au gouvernement de
façon un peu unilatérale et
discontvenante en séance d'apporter par
amendement une réécriture totale de la
solution de la VAE en article sur
l'article premier nous avons été aussi
force de proposition avec un apport
législatif conséquent sur l'abandon de
poste
nous déplorons toutefois que sur la
notion d'offres raisonnable d'emploi la
fameuse ore ou sur la question du refus
d'assaini après un CDD votre majorité le
gouvernement ne nous est pas permis
d'aller au-delà et de répondre à ce que
nous considérons comme étant une
nécessité en responsabilité je vous l'ai
dit nous avons pris ce texte à bras le
corps en étant force de proposition en
cherchant à améliorer en responsabilité
compte tenu de la contrainte qui nous a
imposée de permettre l'indemnisation des
chômeurs nous voterons ce texte mais
monsieur le ministre je vous le dis
d'emblée nous serons présents et avec
force l'encore lors de la présentation
de la future vraie réforme de
l'assurance chômage que nous attendons
de nos vœux
je vous remercie
la parole
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission mais sur la
plante en général mes chers collègues
ce sujet ce texte concernant l'assurance
chômage
c'est pas une petite question et depuis
30 ans dans ce pays c'est un sujet
absolument majeur parce que combien de
gouvernements ont rencontré tellement de
difficultés pour faire en sorte qu'on
apporte madame panot au demandeur
d'emploi que nous connaissons aussi bien
que vous des réponses qu'il méritent et
qu'on apporte aux entreprises les
réponses qu'elles attendent
ce texte monsieur le ministre n'a pas
pris prétention à tout régler du monde
imaginer que c'était le grand débat où
on allait faire en sorte que tous les
outils soient à nos dispositions pour
demain améliorer le marché de l'emploi
non ce texte c'était déjà d'ailleurs ça
n'a pas été rappelé auparavant permettre
au demeure d'emploi d'avoir encore la
garantie des versements d'unité chômage
parce que sinon il y avait la difficulté
qui était la note de l'insécurité
juridique je préfère le redire parce que
ce texte non plus ne cèle pas
définitivement les règles
d'indemnisation chômage elle les règles
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2023 et que je
sache les ministres ont écrit au
partenaires sociaux en leur disant de
choses on va modifier ses règles mais
surtout ensemble on va écrire les règles
du paritarisme parce que nous nous
sommes les démocrates non de la sérénité
active qui anime Jean-Paul Mathis
attachée à cette notion du paritarisme
ça ne peut pas être les patrons d'un
côté ça ne peut pas être les salariés de
l'autre ça ne peut pas être le
gouvernement ça doit être aussi le
Parlement alors avec ce test que nous
avons devant nous est-ce que oui ou non
déjà cette assurance nous l'apportons la
réponse est oui la seconde d'ailleurs je
suis un peu surpris de voir que
naturellement lorsqu'ils explications de
vote il y a toujours les effets de
tribune
il y a eu beaucoup de sérénité dans les
débats et je pense que Marc ferrachi le
sait excellent connaisseur de ces
questions il y a jamais eu de
débordements verbaux madame la
Présidente bien au contraire un débat
projet contre projet et on voyait bien
qu'elles étaient
les idées des uns et les idées des
autres moi ce que je vois c'est qu'il y
a eu des avancées incontestables dans ce
pays on pouvait pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
un problème d'emploi lorsqu'il y a un
million d'emplois madame panot qui ne
sont pas pourvus ces millions d'emplois
c'est notre responsabilité que de les
pourvoirs mais
accordez-moi aussi et d'ailleurs pas un
mot n'a été dit sur le fait que les
règles d'indemnisation chômage qu'on
aille mis en place en 2017 ne peuvent
pas être les mêmes lorsque taux de
chômage a singulièrement baissé dans ce
pays par un seul orateur de la gauche ce
lundi ça doit vous ennuyer
alors pour autant beaucoup restent à
faire et soyons modestes et c'est une
première étape je le dis aux deux
ministres qui sont devant moi pour dans
ces chantiers que vous avez ouvert
trouver les solutions du futur parce que
je pense que entre la préférence
nationale et la paresse il y a un chemin
c'est celui qu'on vous propose on a
avancé sur les abandons de poste ça
n'est pas mon cousin qu'il a dit à ma
cousine qui en pense que mon oncle n'ont
pas du tout venez dans les entreprises
avec nous et vous verrez que c'est une
réalité le deuxième sujet sur les CDD je
vous entends j'ai pas entendu sur les
CDD la taxation des contrats courts qui
ont coûté 9 milliards d'euros à
l'inédits heureusement mais oui monsieur
Bompard heureusement qu'on les attaques
c'est car le CDD c'est l'insécurité les
CDD c'est la précarité et la précarité
vous voulez l'entretenir
alors
le chemin est devant nous le cheval
devant nous pour un sujet qui n'est pas
réglé et c'est vrai c'est cette affaire
de CDI qu'on propose à des gens qui sont
en CDD qui ne les prennent pas les
ministres sont engagés pour que le
Parlement soit associé à la démarche je
voudrais un terminé je le dis à la
ministre par la VAE
avec ce que nous votons sur la VAE
et réfléchissons bien avant de voter ce
texte la validation des acquis
d'expérience tout le monde en parle
personne l'a fait
et là on va ouvrir une voie pour 100000
personnes dès 2023 la VAE c'est une
reconnaissance pierre Dary will ne me
contredira pas puisqu'il a soutenu cet
amendement qu'il est intervenu à
plusieurs reprises la VAE quelque part
c'est pour des femmes et des hommes la
possibilité de se former d'avancer
d'avoir de nouvelles qualifications
d'avoir des meilleurs rémunérations bref
d'être reconnus alors mes chers
collègues il faudra avancer avec des
nouvelles règles contracycliques parce
que quand ça va bien on doit moins
indemniser quand ça va mal on anime 10
plus c'est ça aussi le système
assurance-viel c'est ça 45 l'héritage le
pays qui aide ce qui souffre et oui ça
vous ennuie mais c'est la vérité alors
mes chers collègues le groupe démocrate
votre assiette mais Monsieur Madame la
Ministre seront au rendez-vous pour la
VAE sera au rendez-vous pour les cddcdi
et sera au rendez-vous pour atteindre le
plan d'emploi
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Arthur de la
porte pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame la
Présidente
les réformes doivent apporter le progrès
pas la régression
c'est juste Maxime c'est vous qui la
prononciez il y a 11 ans Monsieur le
Ministre lorsque vous étiez porte-parole
de Martine Aubry ces mots il raisonne
aujourd'hui tragiquement dans cette
émission puisque lorsque l'ancienne
ministre du travail était à votre place
en 2000 elle estimée et je la cite que
l'indemnisation des chômeurs vocation
première du régime d'assurance chômage
devait être amélioré et notamment pour
celles et ceux qui travaillent à temps
partiel et pour les jeunes
22 ans plus tard vous ne promettez plus
le progrès mais bien une triple
régression celle des droits et de la
condition des chômeurs celle du dialogue
social et pour finir celle du débat
parlementaire parce que oui vous avez
ignoré avec des nains cette hémicycle
oubliez vos grands discours sur la
démocratie nous devrions pourtant nous y
habituer oublier les syndicats et les
principes fondamentaux du dialogue
social Vous refusez la négociation vous
mettez fin à 64 ans de paritarisme et
vous nous demandez aujourd'hui de voter
un chèque en blanc pour réformer sans
contrainte et par décret mais aucun de
nous amendements même les plus petits
garde-fous n'a été retenu comment
l'accepter quand vous cédez en même
temps le terrain à la droite et au
patronat alors que va être réforme ne
vise qu'à faire des économies vous avez
ignoré les économistes et même les
rapports implacables de votre
administration les praticiens du droit
les jurys spécialistes de l'assurance
chômage
ignorer aussi les agents de Pôle Emploi
qui dénoncent depuis 2019 vos réformes
lisibles ces unies à gaz que vous montez
successivement et que nul ne comprend
enfin vous n'avez même pas pris la peine
d'écouter les premiers concernés les
chômeurs nous avons pourtant tenté de
porter la voix de Bertrand de Pauline
souvenant non de Pauline de Christine de
Zahia
de ces millions d'individus que votre
précédente réforme après carrisé il vous
suffit d'aller les voir dans les agences
de Pôle emploi plus d'un million d'entre
elles et eux a perdu en moyenne 150
euros par mois aujourd'hui vous nous
promettez non seulement de renforcer
cette sinistre mécanique mais aussi de
fixer la location en fonction de la
loterie de la conjoncture économique
vous promettiez un droit clair et
simplifié vous transformez désormais les
chômeurs en Madame Irma de
l'imprévisibilité de vos terribles de
vos terribles réformes comprennent qui
pourra à cela s'ajoute un autre mépris
et même un autre déni celui de la
réalité la réalité c'est d'abord la
situation dans laquelle se retrouve les
chômeurs ceux qui profiteraient selon
vous d'indemnités indus au lieu de
retrouver du travail mais enfin on ne
refuse pas un travail parce qu'on est
sous indemnisé ou trop indemnisé la
réalité c'est qu'il y a trop d'offres
sous-payés pour des emplois de mauvaise
qualité c'est cela la réalité les
problèmes de mobilité ou de garde qui
sont les principaux freins à l'emploi
mais vous fermez les yeux et vous
préférez réformer à l'aveugle la réalité
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
c'est qu'à peine plus d'un tiers des
chômeurs touchent une allocation chômage
la réalité c'est les 700 000 chômeurs
qui auraient le droit à une
indemnisation mais qui ne l'a demandé
pas nous avons proposé des amendements
pour améliorer l'accès aux droits lutter
contre ce nouveau recours balayer par
votre majorité refuser par votre
gouvernement la réalité c'est aussi une
réalité budgétaire votre réforme n'est
pas nécessaire les annexes au projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale publié ces jours-ci annonce même
que l'assurance chômage sera tenez-vous
bien excédentaire de 4,5 milliards
d'euros en 2023 c'est ça la réalité la
réalité c'est celle du saccage du droit
du travail auquel vous procédez votre
précédent très forme a mis fin à la
logique même de l'assurance chômage en
intégrant des périodes non travaillées
dans le calcul de l'indemnité nous
sommes les seuls au monde à procéder
ainsi vous cherchez aujourd'hui certes à
vous rapprocher d'un autre modèle le
modèle canadien dont tout le monde et
même les Canadiens reconnaît l'absurdité
c'est peut-être la fraude alors qui
serait un moteur de votre réforme mais
vous comptez alors pénaliser l'immense
majorité au nom d'une infime minorité
c'est cela votre manière de procéder et
enfin et j'en finirai là vous avez cédé
sur l'essentiel les principes
les réformes doivent apporter le progrès
disiez vous pas la régression mais avec
la présomption de démission sur les
abandons de poste vous créez là un
monstre juridique qui va à l'encontre de
35 ans de jurisprudence du droit du
travail ce cadeau vous le faites à la
droite de cette hémicycle il est
inacceptable alors Monsieur le Ministre
madame la ministre au nom du plein
emploi décidément non on ne peut pas
tout faire pour cela et pour le reste
nous voterons contre
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
valtoux pour le groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur mais mes
chers collègues
l'équation politique de notre assemblée
amène régulièrement certains à
s'interroger sur notre capacité
collective amenée à bien des débats de
fonds et constructifs des débats qui
concilient la recherche d'une majorité
tout en respectant la vie de chacun ou
du moins du plus grand nombre à cette
tribune je veux témoigner qu'avec ce
projet loi sur le fonctionnement du
marché du travail nous avons réussi et
finalement de belles manières nous avons
réussi à faire mentir les sceptiques en
ayant eu depuis deux semaines en
commission puis en séance des débats à
danse et fouiller qui ont privilégié
l'écoute de chacun avec à l'arrivée la
prise en compte d'un grand nombre d'avis
et de propositions
issues des différentes banques de notre
assemblée
au nom du groupe horizon je tiens ainsi
à saluer l'ensemble des parlementaires
qui dans un esprit contre constructif et
loin des caricatures ont pris part aux
discussions je tiens je tiens à saluer
l'esprit de dialogue du gouvernement
autour de vous chez Olivier du soft que
de vous cherchent Carole Grandjean ainsi
que le travail du rapporteur notre
collègue Marc Ferracci pour son
engagement merci pour son engagement et
son écoute facilité par sa connaissance
reconnue de ces sujets le texte qui nous
est soumis aujourd'hui traduit une
position d'équilibre ce qui est pour moi
une grande qualité s'agissant de cette
matière complexe qu'elle accompagnement
de ceux qui sont confrontés à des
ruptures dans leur parcours
professionnel équilibre d'abord entre
ceux qui auraient voulu à travers ce
texte traité de l'ensemble des
politiques publiques de l'emploi ceux
qui ont fait qu'exprimer leurs
obsessions nationalistes et ceux qui
rêvent un grand soir ont défendu l'idée
d'un État qui s'effacerait dans la
définition des règles qui encadre le
régime d'assurance chômage pour donner
tout pouvoir sans régulation au seul
syndicat au final et on le dira jamais
assez la voie choisie et celle qui
privilégie le dialogue social pour
déterminer les nouvelles règles de
l'assurance chômage ainsi que l'avenir
de sa gouvernance équilibre ensuite
s'agissant des dispositifs encadrant la
VAE il était temps de renforcer la
reconnaissance de ce parcours de
qualification et le gouvernement a eu
raison dans un travail itératif avec
plusieurs groupes de notre assemblée
d'enrichir ce dispositif de dispositions
formulées sur plusieurs de nos bancs
avec la groupe avec le groupe horizon
nous nous réjouissons de la prise en
compte de plusieurs de nos propositions
et amendements je pense d'abord à la
relance de l'expérimentation des CDD de
multi remplacement le recours au CDD de
remplacement constitue une véritable
voix d'entrée vers l'emploi une solution
à la fois bénéfique pour les entreprises
et efficaces contre la répétition des
contrats
l'instauration sous ces conditions
précises d'une présomption simple de
démission du salarié quand ce dernier
qui de volontairement son poste porté
par mon collègue François Gernigon était
également une mesure attendue nous
devrons veiller à sa bonne application
et rester vigilant nous sommes heureux
enfin d'avoir oeuvré au renforcement de
l'information du Parlement sur
l'efficacité des contrôles effectués par
Pôle emploi en matière d'offres
raisonnable d'emploi ces données
permettront à la fois déclarer le débat
public mais aussi de mesurer
l'efficacité des politiques pubs
économiques et de l'ensemble des
dispositifs déployés
ces apports de notre groupe
correspondent à notre volonté partagée
par tous les groupes de la magie de la
majorité pardon de rendre plus efficace
le marché du travail dans la droite
ligne de la réforme de 2019 portée par
le gouvernement à leur dirigé par
Edouard Philippe à ceux qui nous
expliquent que ce projet loi est un
texte pour rien faut-il que nous leur
rappelions le contexte singulier dans
lequel nous sommes et les défis que nous
devrons relever dans les prochains mois
aujourd'hui nous l'avons que trop dit
les difficultés de recrutement
coexistent avec un chômage trop élevé
alors même que les transformations de
l'économie offrent de nouvelles
perspectives et de création d'emplois
ce texte trouve donc tout son sens en
visant à la fois l'objectif de plein
emploi d'une part et la refondation de
notre modèle d'assurance chômage d'autre
part ce texte participe aussi à protéger
l'avenir de ce modèle précieux que nous
souhaitons garantir en l'adaptant aux
évolutions de notre société et à la
réalité du monde du travail
garantir d'abord la pérennité de ce
modèle pour qu'il puisse rester
réellement protecteur en période de
crise et agile face aux évolutions de
l'économie garantir ensuite
l'adaptabilité de ce modèle pour mieux
que le coordonner avec les prestations
sociales et les règles fiscales afin
qu'ils soient toujours plus incitatif au
retour à l'emploi garantir enfin la
légitimité de ce modèle en souhaitant
que sa gouvernance soit plus efficace et
qu'elle permet un équilibre réel où
chaque acteur soit pleinement reconnu en
ouverture de nos débats j'avais souhaité
au nom du groupe horizon que la
discussion sur ce test sur ce texte
puisse permettre une discussion
constructive sur un sujet essentiel j'ai
la satisfaction de constater que pour la
majorité d'entre nous nous avons été à
la hauteur si nous ne sommes pas sur
tout montrant à l'occasion de ce projet
loi que nous pouvons nous retrouver en
majorité sur l'essentiel l'ensemble du
groupe horizon de votre a ce texte avec
force et conviction je vous en remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
il reste encore trois orateurs et je
fais annoncer le scrutin dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Madame marais Charlotte
Guérin pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre madame la ministre
monsieur rapporteur madame la Présidente
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre du soft nous avons
convenu dès le départ que nous ne
partageions pas la même vision de la
société et du travail avec ce texte vous
imaginez l'assurance chômage comme un
levier pour le plein emploi que vous
actionnez en fonction de la situation
économique du pays je dis imaginez parce
qu'il n'y a absolument rien qui
soutiennent votre théorie pour l'instant
le seul levier actionné par votre
réforme de 2019 c'est celui de la misère
pour plusieurs millions de français et
de français
avec ce texte vous cherchez surtout à
faire des économies et peu importe le
prix peu importe l'augmentation de la
précarité pour les personnes en
recherche d'emploi puisque vous avez
déjà économisé 2 milliards sur leur dos
et vous allez continuer
alors que s'est-il passé depuis le début
de notre débat sur ce texte la liste est
longue et symptomatique d'abord la douce
musique de la nouvelle méthode et déjà
en train de s'éteindre sans surprise
c'est vers la droite de l'hémicycle que
vous êtes allé faire des alliances et
c'est avec la droite que vous avez
choisi d'instaurer une nouveauté la
présomption de démission un abandon de
poste ne permettra plus d'accéder à
l'indemnisation chômage et c'est
pourtant parfois la seule solution pour
bien des salariés
de notre côté nous avons proposé de
seulement prolonger les règles
actuellement en vigueur pour éviter le
pire nous avons proposé de ramener la
négociation et le dialogue social dans
ce texte comme nous avons proposé de
lutter contre la cause structurelle du
chômage qui est le capitalisme
climaticide et déréglé
ensuite
le seul amendement du peste que vous
avez accepté en commission a été celui
qui demandait un rapport un rapport
attendu depuis plusieurs années déjà le
rapport en question nous a été remis le
lundi soir au début de l'examen du texte
et on peut se dire avec indulgence que
ça arrive que les services sont
particulièrement occupés et qu'un
rapport de plus ou moins ça ne fait pas
grande différence seulement voilà ce
rapport-là il nous indique qu'il y a 25
à 42% des personnes en situation de
recherche d'emploi qui ne demandent pas
à être indemnisé alors qu'elle le
pourrait et là on se dit vraiment qu'on
fait erreur avec ce texte sur
l'assurance chômage parce qu'au lieu de
lutter contre le non recours d'essayer
de répondre au pourquoi derrière cette
part immense de personnes qui ne
bénéficient pas de l'assurance chômage
alors qu'elle le pourrait on décide de
précariser un peu plus les chômeurs
enfin il y a eu la validation des acquis
de l'expérience un article qui devait
simplement concerner les proches aidants
malgré toutes les réserves qui ont été
exprimées ici et par les professionnels
de santé et bien cet article ça devient
discrètement en séance une réforme à
part entière sans nous laisser le temps
du débat et sans laisser à ce sujet la
place et le travail qu'il mérite dans
cette émission
de notre côté nous avons défendu une
autre assurance chômage une assurance
chômage aux mains des partenaires
sociaux avec de réelles négociations une
assurance chômage qui reste un droit
parce que les Français et les Françaises
cotisent une assurance chômage pour tous
et toutes avec la fin du non recours et
enfin une assurance chômage couplée à
une vraie politique de formation et donc
avec des moyens conséquents
finalement nous avons esquissé les
contours de ce que pourrait être une
révolution du temps libéré
et quand j'interroge les gens autour de
moi et d'autant plus depuis le covid il
y a un déclic
pas parce que les gens veulent
travailler moins et je crois que tous et
tous ici nous connaissons des personnes
passionnées par leur métier qui ne
comptent pas leurs heures et peut-être
même qu'on a eu la chance d'en faire
partie avant notre mandat mais parce que
tous et toutes nous voulons travailler
mieux et cela passe par de meilleurs
salaires bien sûr par de meilleures
conditions de travail cela passe par des
contrôles aussi et ils sont insuffisants
quand on sait qu'il y a actuellement en
France un inspecteur du travail pour
10000 salariés
chers collègues
savoir si le travail est de droite ou de
gauche je crois que les Français et les
Français sont contrefichent en revanche
nous sommes nombreux et nombreuses à
vouloir que le travail ne soit pas le
pilier central de nos vies mais
simplement un pilier parmi d'autres au
même titre que le temps que l'on veut
passer avec nos proches que l'engagement
citoyen qu'on peut avoir dans des
associations et que le temps qu'on peut
passer simplement pour soi enfin
retrouver
est-ce que vous pouvez imaginer un
instant ce que permettrait la juste
place du travail dans nos vies parce
qu'un travail qui occupe la juste place
et pas toute la place ça veut dire du
temps pour recréer du lien avec les
autres du temps pour se reconnecter au
vivant du temps pour choisir de ralentir
et cela veut aussi dire vivre au mieux
et plus longtemps en résumé
nous sommes contre votre méthode et
contre l'esprit de votre projet nous
sommes contre la reprise en main du
régime d'assurance chômage par l'État et
contre la précarisation des personnes
sans emploi et nous voterons contre ce
texte je vous remercie
la parole
est à Monsieur Pierre dareville pour le
groupe GDR
madame la Présidente Monsieur Madame la
Ministre chers et chers collègues
je voudrais travailler encore travailler
encore forger la scie rouge avec mes
mains d'or voilà ce que disent avec
Bernard Lavilliers la plupart de celles
et ceux qui sont privés de travail je
voudrais travailler encore travailler
tout court
mais ce que vous sous-entendez sous le
vernis des mots polissés c'est que les
privés d'emploi sont des coquins des
resquilleurs l'assurance chômage
dites-vous et trop généreuse pas assez
incitative même si un tiers des
personnes éligibles ne font pas valoir
leur droit pour vous c'est elle qui
empêche de gagner la bataille de
l'emploi c'est de la faute de
l'assurance chômage s'il y a du chômage
il faudrait donc la dégrader pour forcer
celles et ceux qui se compléraient dans
sa ouate à ne pas être trop regardant et
à prendre le premier emploi qui passe
sans en discuter les conditions il
faudrait rendre le chômage plus terrible
encore mais le chômage est toujours une
épreuve il vous plonge dans
l'incertitude abîme l'estime de soi
détruit des vies et face à lui
l'assurance chômage est un droit créée
par le travail pour l'affronter le droit
à être protégé grâce à sa cotisation à
recevoir un revenu remplacement
lorsqu'on est privé d'emplois le temps
de retrouver un autre travail qui vous
correspondent et parce que le travail
change il faudrait sécuriser les
parcours professionnels entre emploi et
formation alors vous vous trompez sur
toute la ligne votre réforme est injuste
bancal et inefficace inefficace sur les
tensions dans certains secteurs du
marché de l'emploi comme on dit avec des
guillemets
l'assurance chômage n'est pas un levier
de la politique d'emploi c'est un droit
ce ne doit pas être un droit flou et
flottant variable au gré de la
conjoncture mais un droit stable pour
imposer cette régression vous nous
demandez de vous signer une décharge
afin de court-circuiter à nouveau les
acteurs sociaux après une mauvaise
réforme qui a dégradé la vie d'un bon
million de personnes vous poursuivez les
tatisations de la protection sociale et
sa transformation en assistance publique
votre allergie à la protection sociale
vous emporte
vous annoncez une réforme de la
gouvernance de l'inédith une réforme du
service public de l'emploi une réforme
du RSA vous avez cédé au MEDEF et aux
républicains sur les abandons de poste
sans vous interroger plus loin sur ces
situations déjà prévues au passage et
sur leur cause et vous leur en promettez
à eux et à d'autres sur l'obligation
d'accepter un CDI il faut mettre les
gens dans des cases ne leur déplaise
vous jouez à Tetris avec les vies il
faut empiler tout ça pour faire des
lignes et des colonnes vous vous trompez
sur toutes les lignes et sur toutes les
colonnes et comme une provocation
supplémentaire vous avez choisi de
produire à la sauvage une réforme
d'ensemble de la validation des acquis
de l'expérience ce droit des salariés
nous le défendons mais vous n'avez
vraiment discuté de tout cela avec
personne et il est à craindre que cette
réforme s'inscrive
dans cette volonté de décréter au plus
vite les gens utilisables employables et
rentables alors que la reconnaissance de
leur expérience et de leur expertise si
difficile dans un trop grand nombre
d'endroits devraient s'articuler avec la
formation professionnelle qualifiante et
les métiers pour pouvoir s'épanouir dans
un travail et non pas devenir un outil
supplémentaire de contournement des
diplômes et des salaires pendant des
décennies le système a prospérer sur un
chômage de masse et nous n'en sommes pas
sortis il pesait sur les salaires les
conditions de travail les droits
aujourd'hui alors que le rapport de
force semble un peu s'améliorer pour les
salariés la vérité c'est que vous ne
l'acceptez pas vous le montrez
d'ailleurs à propos des mouvements pour
les salaires dans les raffineries ce
texte est un geste de classe pas au sens
du beau geste non au sens d'un geste de
lutte des classes interrogez-vous plutôt
sur les conséquences de l'insécurité
sociale interrogez-vous
sur les causes des tensions sur le
marché de l'emploi interrogez-vous sur
la reconnaissance interrogez-vous sur la
case des métiers interrogez-vous sur la
crise de sens interrogez-vous sur
l'instrumentalisation des humains pour
des profits dont ils ne voient pas la
couleur interrogez-vous sur le travail
sur la crise du travail qui mine notre
société mais vous allez encore alimenter
cette machine puis vous viendrez nous
expliquer que vous ne comprenez pas
qu'il y ait des gens qui éprouvent du
mal-être au travail nous nous croyons au
travail comme une contribution de
chacune et chacun la réponse aux besoins
comme un geste d'accomplissement comme
un geste de partage mais encore faut-il
le respecter avec cette réforme vous
vous attaquez encore à celle des ceux
qui travaillent et les prétend comme des
enfants turbulents à celles et ceux qui
voudraient travailler encore travailler
encore ce sont les mêmes pour les
députés communistes et le groupe GDR
c'est non
je vous remercie
dernière intervenant
dernière intervenant Monsieur Olivier
Servat pour le groupe Lyot
[Applaudissements]
madame monsieur les ministres monsieur
le rapporteur cher collègue
je ne vais pas faire durer le suspense
les députés de mon groupe ne voteront
pas ce texte
et cette position s'explique autant par
le fond de la réforme que vous proposez
que par la méthode que vous privilégiez
écoute concertation co-construction les
engagements du mois de juillet n'ont pas
fait long feu et la méthode promise
semble avoir été remisée en contournant
allègrement partenaires sociaux et
parlementaires
quel est le symbole envoyé pour les 5
prochaines années quand sur un sujet
aussi crucial que la police du travail
le gouvernement décide de fixer les
règles par décret autrement dit seul
surtout les débats ces dernières
semaines ne nous ont pas convaincus
quant à la pertinence de lier les règles
des mises à la conjoncture économique
d'autant qu'au moment de voter ce texte
ne savons toujours pas sur quelle base
et quel indicateur seront-ils utilisés
le taux de chômage le taux de vacances
d'emploi et quelle fréquence selon
quelle fréquence les règles seront
corrigées
notre groupe n'a finalement obtenu
qu'une seule garantie que ses futurs
règles si elles comptent des
spécificités des territoires d'outre-mer
confrontés à des taux de chômage bien
plus importants mais avec des
opportunités d'emploi moins bien
nombreuses c'était le minimum monsieur
le ministre nous avons pu échanger j'ai
entendu vos ansagement pour la bonne
mise en oeuvre de ces adaptations et
pour assurer des règles plus
protectrices dans cet territoire plus
fragile nous y veillerons
tout comme nous garderons un oeil sur
l'impact de votre réforme sur les taux
de non recours aujourd'hui 25 à 42% des
personnes éligibles à l'indemnisation
chômage de la touche pas
plus globalement je crois qu'un copier
était possible sur ce texte une solution
d'équilibre aurait permis de prendre le
temps de débattre pour une réforme plus
ambitieuse cette solution notre groupe
la proposer dès le départ pourrez à
l'identique le régime actuel
de 6 mois par exemple le temps que les
partenaires sociaux négocient de
nouvelles règles le temps aussi de
prendre un peu de recul sur la dernière
réforme d'assurance chômage qui
n'attendrait en vigueur que l'an dernier
et déjà dans la douleur comme et contre
la vie des partenaires sociaux surtout
je crois que ce projet de loi est né
d'une erreur celle de quoi qu'il suffit
de restreindre les mises à chômage pour
lutter contre les difficultés de
recrutement des entreprises le chômage
est un risque économique et social
auquel chacun d'entre nous ne peut être
confronté au cours de sa carrière et
doit l'assumer être demandeur d'emploi
ce n'est pas l'état permanent mais une
situation temporaire et l'indemnisation
chômage permet justement d'en sortir
sans tomber dans la pauvreté ne tombons
pas dans les discours réducteurs nous
posons pas travailleurs et demandeur
d'emploi aussi nous regrettons que ce
projet de loi se soit concentré presque
exclusivement sur l'assurance chômage
alors une réflexion globale sur l'emploi
et sur le travail qu'il aurait fallu
mener
l'objectif du plein emploi nous leur
partageons bien évidemment pour
l'atteindre nous devons activer tous les
leviers formation accompagnement
mobilité logement garde d'enfants tout
cela nous l'avons dit en 20
réformer le travail implique sur tout de
répondre aux attentes nouvelles de nos
citoyens la question des conditions de
travail doit donc être posée l'épidémie
de covid avait amorcé une réflexion sur
la reconnaissance sociale et salariale
de tous ces emplois que l'on rémunère si
mal qu'en reste-t-il aujourd'hui
quid également des taux d'emploi des
signaux qui restent en deçà de nos
partenaires européens trop longtemps on
a favorisé les départs anticipés les
mises à l'écart or les seniors ont
encore beaucoup à offrir d'autres
questions mériteraient des réponses taux
d'emploi des jeunes partage la valeur au
sein d'entreprise la gouvernance nous
sommes prêts à travailler avec vous pour
trouver des solutions novatrices et
juste
disons cela je pense évidemment à la
réforme de notre système de retraite qui
arrive je ne voudrais pas que le débat
ne soit que comptable qu'il ne porte que
sur la question de l'âge légal de départ
nous devons aborder vraiment la question
des carrières longues de la prise en
charge effective de la pénibilité en
d'autres termes je ne voudrais pas que
parce que le président a décidé que la
réforme devrait être bouquet avant l'été
que nous reproduisons les mêmes effets
erreurs que sur ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie mon cher
collègue
je vais donner mettre voix le projet de
loi tout le monde a pu regagner sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin
et Claude
votant 563 exprimé 552 majorités 277
pour 303 contre 249 l'Assemblée
nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]